we're gonna get one sequence where all
the male superheroes are shirtless yes
and they're all just touching each
other's ex but if they just stand there
and then they just start doing it yeah
cuz them all is like rubbing each
other's chests together back circle that
I feel like they've been built as much
as the building of Thanos maybe building
up the marvel body shots
hey reject nation Greg Alba here
Courtney Scott right over here please
follow her on Instagram I sure do and
follow her on Twitter as a 20 minutes
ago I definitely do too so make sure to
check her out over there you might have
seen her on the javi Kuwait Channel
first time I met Courtney was about
maybe a year ago I got introduced to you
through my brother and he said that
you're like a big comic book fan so I've
always want to bring you up or something
comic book related and I thought hey I
want to do some predictions there's
there's at least a couple yeah long
overdue let's do an actual prediction
video here let's cash in on all those
YouTube videos that do predictions like
the chairs do fart noises yeah
professionalism at its best people now
where do we begin with some predictions
we want to make on this let me just get
this out of the way all right for sure
spider-man and black panther dead right
away I think that's gonna be the big
surprise is Oh people we thought would
get more movies I'm sure they were gonna
blow up with Conda and then what kind of
just blew up yeah they were like oh
let's go back and reshoot we didn't
think people would think infinity
whereas to compete with Black Panther
very upset they killed any of them I
have a prediction on how I think some
plot points will play out which from
watching the trailers three times
because I don't watch anything more than
that on my own time I feel like the
movie will probably start with Thor
because Thor Ragnarok that wasn't the
post-credit when he bumps into Thanos
his ship so I feel like it'll it'll
start right there they have all those
shots with the I'm not gonna be the most
articulate this video let you guys know
that with Thor was like you're trying to
keep the ship together he's gonna get
caught and then that's when Loki gives
over the tesseract to Thanos and I think
in that scene too yeah this is just the
first time in snow
because based on what we saw from the
clip in the trailer trip yeah he's like
you know somewhere that's probably act
two of when this is all going down when
everything's gonna start getting crazy
if there's gonna be a lot of setup but I
feel like when things start kicking into
gear first person that is gonna
encounter Thanos in the black order will
be Thor I agree oh yes oh thank god one
point for Greg that's true because I
think for him to end up with the
guardians in some way you know something
must have happened with that [ __ ] if the
Thor comic book has anything to do with
that cuz you know I don't know if you
know a scar does actually blow up in the
comics at some point during that and
then new Asgard I think is like
somewhere in like either Arizona or New
Mexico I remember there there is a new
Asgard that is in a kind of list I get
the feeling Loki's going to die in that
moment like a lot of people are
predicting that I think I think Loki my
dies he's in like no other scenes in the
trailer he's kind of the magista cousin
anyway yeah that's actually an Avenger
he's not actually a bad guy anymore I
just don't know why phantoms he would
kill him when Loki is honoring what he
said he would do from the first Avengers
that whole theory with Thanos holding
Thor's head and making him watched Loki
die makes sense to me and so I think
that's how somehow Thor escapes cuz I
don't think that's on earth when this is
happening I think it's a different
planet and I think when Thor escapes
that's when he's flying through space
and that's when he bumps into the
guardians cuz oh they have that one
thing where he like lands on the window
of the guardians and he tells the
guardians and he's like yo I'm the one
who put the mind stone in visions head
and that's on earth so we got to get to
earth right away and I read the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book now I haven't read
that one oh you have it oh well after
reading it I could tell you it is no way
a waste of time because it's gonna be
100% like no it's great nothing like
this guy
just like so many more characters and
other characters that play a much bigger
role but how they get fini commonly
comic happens is like when and
everything starts going crazy it's
because like half the population just
sort of disappears that includes a lot
of superheroes Silver Surfer and Adam
warlock are a big factor in that comic
book that's what I'm wondering is
because Adam warlock and Silver Surfer
first encounter Doctor Strange and
that's what seems reminiscent to me
about when Bruce Banner shows up he's
kind of doing what Silver Surfer did
when he's like yeah well I just showed
up at your place Wong dr. strange
there's a dude named Santo is coming I
got to tell you about it because I'm
sure somehow he contacts some here's my
prediction
I think phantoms blows up Thor has with
his like refugees from ad I think that's
how the Hulk crash lands into the doctor
strange what's it called someone that
appears in Thor Ragnarok and doctor all
that stuff yeah i think i think the hoax
gonna land I think that's how Thor gets
thrown into the guardianship then that
might also be how Loki ends up down
there cuz we all knew that he stole the
tesseract yeah from Ragnarok so I think
that's how he lands up and I think
that's how a nose gets the tesseract
from him Guardians they're all powerful
anyway so saying like well I think I'm
one of them I'm going to die because
when Loki hands over the tesseract and
you can see in the trailer there's a
shot of one woman at least I remember
who's dead and she kind of has he has
Guardian outfit on so it looks like
there's a massacre of like a bunch of
Asgardian yeah yeah so then actually the
next Thor is just him just reproducing
[Laughter]
yeah I mean eyes I think a big thing
that I don't think I've heard anyone
touched on because of how important Adam
warlock is in the Infinity Gauntlet
comic book like he is arguably the most
important character in that comic book
besides that
of course and they tease him at the end
of guardians to him and Thanos have a
whole history with each other even
though guardians to made it seem like
Adam warlock is just being created he's
the one who leads all the people into
how to take down Thanos in the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book and they tease him
in Guardians 2 yet I feel like no one's
really bringing him up if anything we'll
probably have another post-credit scene
where we get to see Adam warlock in full
creation but you don't think he's gonna
be in infinity I don't think he'll be in
the movie infinity war but I think he'll
probably be in like a mid credit scene
or a post-credits scene or like towards
the end he might make an appearance
which is segue into part 4 oh yeah I
think in this one they're all gonna lose
I don't think all gonna die but I think
in part 4 is when they have a victory I
think the part one has to be depressing
part 2 is Victoria yes that's what I
think it has to be right that makes
sense I wanted to do a part wanted to do
because Avengers 4 isn't technically the
part to you know because originally
there were supposed to be the two films
the Russo brothers said there wasn't
gonna be infinity War part 1 and part 2
that they were gonna do infinity war in
this whole film and that there would be
a part 4 but it wasn't necessarily
connected to infinity voice I've heard
that venture spoors title is a spoiler
for infinity war I think it is a spoiler
for the outcome of what happens in
infinity war but I think infinity war is
going to be like complete oh no I don't
think that at all I just I think because
they said that we're not gonna split up
otherwise why would they put that thing
out there saying that it's actually not
gonna be part 1 in part 2 there are
actually two separate entities and see
that they're both separate entities I
still think that they're gonna be linked
to each other heavily and I just can't
imagine you build up a nose for like a
decade and then you don't you get one
movie you defeat him but I do think that
it'll come to a culmination if the
returns even if the combination is he
gets the Infinity Gauntlet by the end of
infinity war if he has the full gauntlet
and then in the next one he does he just
it's like what is he gonna do with it
sure but I think that their war aspect
it is going to be completed yes okay no
man it's about them taking down Thanos
they let him get the gauntlet together
in this I think he's for sure gonna get
down imagine that's how it'll end yes
yeah and then that's when they
time-travel and then Captain Marvel and
then boom and then Adam warlock shows up
saves the day look out for those casting
calls for Adam warlock I'll be
auditioning I think Tony Stark is gonna
die that is what I first thought that
that this would be the right time for
Tony Stark I don't think he'll die till
Avengers 4 and the only reason I say
that is because there was Avengers 4 set
photos released that had Tony Stark yeah
the set photos that just appeared online
with Tony Ant Man Captain America and
cap is actually in his like Avengers
suit so that made me go a lot of people
will probably die and well why would Ant
Man and and and somehow something
happens where they have to time travel
back I think cap will die an infinity
war yeah but then he'll still think but
I think Chris Evans will still come back
as Captain America one more time for
whatever time travel sequencing yeah at
the time stone but I'm also confusing
myself than like well I imagine that
infinity war would every get all six
stones someone else told me that the
soul stone yeah yeah yes that would
makes sense because of how they
communicate with the dead I'm really
curious as to why it didn't come up
during my Panther I'm kind of glad in it
because that's just another piece of
information to explain how they're
communicating I'm sure they can just
throw that in there really quick and
infinity war I would also make more
sense as to why they're having the
battle at Wakanda we have a Tanis once
so that's what we use if they go to
Wakanda if we have vision there with the
mind stone capabilities and then we have
the soul stone we can combine these and
take down fantasy I feel like it's just
so obvious that I'm not I'm not sure we
will only because it just seems way too
like he just got a little human bodies
guys a little girlfriend oh yeah and
they're showing and they're showing
their shots like that I was like pulling
into one of those guys in the blackboard
pulling it out right and I'm like I mean
I don't think they're actually gonna
kill them off only because they feel
like I feel like they're showing so much
in the promos that they're trying to
mislead us
and I think Marvel is clever enough to
mislead us right now right so he might
be out of commission for a little while
taxi they put it back in his face I
think Nick Fury will show up in infinity
war and then Thanos is just gonna smash
him I think it would be really
compelling if Thanos uses the mind stone
to manipulate Scarlet Witch because her
powers were developed in a lab from some
stone in an age of Ultron oh yeah that's
right yeah so if they were able to if
he's able to manipulate Scarlet Witch to
actually kill vision because you see in
the Civil War when she's like vision
with her terrible russian accent puts in
through the wall like startled which is
the one who could take down vision -
right so I think it would be neat if we
had that because I'd be heartbreaking
we're gonna be in store for a lot of
things exciting about Scarlet Witch I
think the female characters might
actually have a lot more to do because
especially in the Infinity Gauntlet
comic book nebula plays a large part and
happy and how they kind of overtake
Thanos it's like it's complicated I
wonder like miss Laroo in the whole
comic book but she does play a large
part it made me go maybe they're they'll
take some type of essence for what they
do with nebula and throw it in here
because nebula is the one character who
arguably has the most personal
motivation to take on Thanos she's
either gonna die trying or she's gonna
help out a lot
Shigure and guardians - and everything
that she and gomorrah kind of broke
through yeah that to me was a powerful
motive absolutely and seen between the
two of them so I would love to see the
two of them kind of team up because of
something they've never done before
they're the ones with the most personal
motivation to take on that exactly so it
needs something to do I imagine them one
of those characters from looking like
that we saw a black panther who survived
will die I think the key is gonna die
really yeah and here's my reason really
marry storm and they're prepping for
that you think they were actually
prepping for that right I don't know but
I know it's it's throughout all the
black panther comic books in history
everyone knows that black panther
marries storms I don't know what we're
gonna do with Nakia because you know
obviously he's a pretty loyal guy unless
she just becomes like storm see
relations we don't know that she has
some some abilities I think we're gonna
get an Abraham and Glenn situation like
Walking Dead one character dies and
you're like oh okay
that's the character and then BOOM a
much bigger your guides
I feel like Kapil could be the bigger
one I feel like we're misleading us with
vision I think will happen at the end of
this movie is he'll get the gauntlet and
then Hawkeye will show up and shoot one
arrow into Thanos eye but when he was
there you never cared like Loki like
okay we saw Loki in one scene we saw how
can one scene that doesn't mean they're
not in yeah they're there believe me I'm
sure they're there guys what predictions
do you have to cap it off Courtney
things Iron Man might die
I think cap well done no I don't think
it anymore everyday with my basic
knowledge yeah Doctor Strange did okay
that's fine Adam warlock will show up
towards the end or at least a mid or
post-credit scene I think you will play
a factor in taking down that us in the
future
Loki died I think and also a sexy scene
with all the heroes with their shirts
off and they're all rubbing each other's
chest together and baby oil and that's
when Shazam shows up The Rock
predictions guys you can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell so it means something
in our lives and also check out Courtney
Scott right on Instagram and Twitter
links to her social media in the
description box and you can also check
us on patreon fooled like TV show
reactions q and A's and also a whole
bunch of goodies would love to have you
behind